what is going on guys my name is Alan
Dru El copygo if you are subscribed to
my email list and know that and today
I'm going to be talking about the future
of copyrighting
2025 we're going to be answering
questions like is it still worth my time
to get into copyrighting in 2025 and if
so what is the best way to do that what
is the path worth pursuing and what is
the path that I should completely avoid
in copyrighting in 2025 we're going to
dive into it but believe me I'm not
going to sit here and just pull things
out of my rear end out of my Caboose no
no no in fact what I've done in 2024 is
I've invested thousands of my personal
dollars to be in private rooms and get
access to knowledge from some of the
greatest copywriters living right now
including people like Kevin Rogers and
Chris oraki Daniel throssel Ben settle
John Carlon and all of these guys to be
in their inner circles to be on their
subscription newsletters and to study
what they are doing as well as what they
are not doing and I want to transfer
that knowledge to you my friend the
copywriter and so let's Dive Right In
actually before we dive in I want to
give you a little tidbit I rebuilt my
website right everything is completely
brand new fresh sexy looking good for
you I want you to go ahead and click the
link in the description below to check
it out and go ahead and subscribe to my
email list if you are not subscribed to
my email list to get the best since
ational storytelling emails on the
market today I want you to go ahead and
grab that jump on to my list and I will
see you in there all right on with the
video now before I get into the
Practical tactical stuff of what's
working in 2024 that's going to continue
working in 2025 tactical right like
should I write ads should I write vssl
should I write emails or thing is email
dead whatever I kind of want to hit some
of the strategical philosophical
thinking of what's going to work because
it's going to get your mindset right to
navigate not just the tactics which come
and go but the way of pursuing yourself
as a copywriter what separates the big
boys from the people that never make it
I want to draw that Line in the Sand and
get you as close to the big boys as
possible alist copywriter Guru mode on
your email list I want you to be that
person so let's dive in what that looks
like answering the first question is is
it still worth it to be a copywriter
coming in 2025 has AI been able to
replace us as copywriters is it going to
replace us as copywriters what should
you be focusing on okay so is it still
worth it to be a copyrighter in 2025 the
answer is a resounding hell yes hell yes
it's still worth it to be a copywriter
in 2025 in fact it's a better time than
ever to be a copywriter in 2025 because
even though the Bots right AI is coming
up and navigating what that looks like
those tools are just there to assist you
as the copywriter to be able to find
gaps and advantages in market research
for your clients better and faster than
ever before now I'm going to come back
to AI but I wanted to establish the
question that this video is not in vain
yes it's absolutely worth it for you to
be a copywriter in 2025 there's plenty
of money to be made the market is not
too saturated because there's not enough
excellence in the market to saturate it
yes there's a lot of copywriters but
there is not enough excellent
copywriters to saturate the market and
so you being really really good is GNA
play a big big role but so now that you
know it's worth it to be a copywriter in
2025 who is going to be the copywriter
that actually makes it in 2025 because I
believe hundreds and millions of you
will say I'm going to be a copywriter
2024 2025 but how are you going to
compete with the goat email go as well
as other people like Kevin Rogers and
Daniel throssel and all these other guys
oh how going to compete with these guys
well I'm going to tell you exactly how
you're going to compete with us and how
you're going to thrive on your own I'm
going to give you three tips for that
right now and the first one being that I
believe the best copywriters in 2025
will be athletes and here's what I mean
by that so many copywriters do not take
care of their body which inherently
jacks up your mind everything is
intertwined okay your your thinking your
Clarity your mental focus your ability
ility to connect ideas together all
stems from the food you eat the exercise
you have right the people that you talk
to the content you consume the content
you don't consume how much screen time
you have on your phone all of those
things drive your ability to be an
excellent athlete which drives your
ability to be an excellent copywriter
because the better you are in shape then
the better copy you're going to write
again body and mind all interconnect Ed
walking lifting running okay Whole Foods
proteins all that stuff now this is not
a health and fitness channel but I take
my health and fitness seriously so how
in the world are you going to compete
against somebody who is taking their
health and fitness seriously but you are
not you're just not going to be able to
and so I truly believe that the first
person that's going to be a winner in
copyrighting in 2025 is the person that
takes their body seriously the athlete
copywriters are athletes the second
thing that I think is going to be
different for winning in copyrighting
for 2025 is the way that I enter the
copyrighting field is no longer
backwards Let Me Explain what that means
so when I started copyrighting a couple
years ago I started very different than
most people okay so most people start
copywriting by reading a couple
copywriting books right maybe taking a
course or two and then reaching out to
clients to write copy for them that is
their introduction to writing copy hey
I'll write some samples for you I kind
of figure this stuff out and blah blah
blah and they they start making some
connections well that's not how I
started copyrighting I started
copyrighting by reading books studying
online and doing things like tweeting
online and building my email list and
writing emails for myself and creating
my own products and selling those own
products what I did was I made myself my
first client this is not typically
something I would recommend to people in
the past but now in 2025 and 2024 it is
absolutely something I'm recommending
and what I'm actually recommending is
that you make yourself your first
copyrighting client because the bar is
higher than ever clients right now are
already utilizing Ai and chat tools and
things like that to help them write
website copy and emails and things like
that which actually it's not bad right
like their AI tools are pretty good AI
is getting pretty good and so it's
actually raise the bar here's the other
thing that's happened with client work
is these legends that I mentioned
earlier the Ben settles the Gary Ben
ofas the Chris or akowski these Legends
have been able to package their
knowledge and put it in a course to be
able to sell it to other copywriters
like myself who now are able to study
their legendary tactics and become
better than ever okay so now the talent
pool has been squished and and I'll talk
about that more in a little bit but with
the talent pool being squished it is
harder than ever to get clients to hire
you to be their copywriter and so what
you actually need behind your belt is
not just skill and talent but you need
proof you need proof that you're good
you need proof that you can sell you
need proof that you know what you're
doing you need examples of having been
done it before and so the best way to do
that write for yourself make your own
products okay and it doesn't to be in
the copyrighting niche like me right
like even though I'm a copywriter who
writes for copywriters that's not what
you have to do that's not even where I
started when I started I talked about
productivity and productivity tools and
I actually wrote copy for productivity
notion templates and products like that
that was my first Niche I enjoyed it
very much but then I was able to help so
many of you copywriters here in this
Niche that I really enjoy helping you
guys and so you might be a a fitness guy
or a gamer or whatever or a health nut
or anything like that so writing copy in
your specific Niche is the best way for
you to be able to practice it build your
own products package those products
create sales page for those products
write website Pages for those products
email sequences post sequences all those
things for you first and then be able to
show your results to other clients if
you want to or honestly you may not ever
have a client if you decide not to maybe
your products take off and that is
actually becoming more normal than ever
so Client List this copyrighting where
you're your own client you never
actually work for someone else is
absolutely a future that you can pay for
yourself in fact uh two of the examples
that I mentioned Ben sedle and Daniel
tho do not take any clients at all I
only have two and that's just basically
because they're good friends of mine
I've been writing copy for them for so
long but honestly I would be able to be
just fine without any clients at all and
so you being your own client is a
massive win for 2025 so if you want to
get in the game
don't worry about getting clients worry
about being your own client building up
the proof building up the skill set
learning how to do everything yourself
and then build relationships that might
get you clients down the line if you
want or build an entire business around
clientless copyrighting that is the
future of 2025 the last philosophical or
strategic idea around the future of
copyrighting and who's actually going to
win is I believe that personality beats
skill set in 2025 now bear with me
because what I didn't say is skill set
is useless no you have to be good in
fact you have to be so good that you
beat the Bots right you have to be
better than AI naturally so we've
already talked about that right where AI
has raised the entry level bar well now
you have to be better than AI okay and
then at the same time the all these
fancy legendary courses which I have
personally invested 5 to 10 to 20,000 of
my own dollars learning from these
courses meaning I have access to the
best best of the best knowledge and so
do you you can buy these courses as well
right so now your skill set level does
have to be high but it is plateaued
where everybody has access to the best
of the best skills they have access to
AI so now skill set is almost plateaued
it's almost given that if you're not
really good you're not even playing in
the same ball field as us right like if
you are not the best or the Bots you're
not even in the game you have to be one
of the other the best or the Bots that's
the only people that are getting hired
or the only people that are getting
really noticed
unless the thing that trumps everything
personality personality is you through
copy okay personality is the fact that I
write to my email list from me and I
talk about my life and my beliefs and
Christianity and the fact that I like
running and the fact that I work out and
I got three kids and all that and person
out and I'm funny and all these things
right and this goes for clients too
right personality goes for clients I
cannot tell you how many client emails
I've made a 100 times better because I
made it come from the founder and I use
the Founder's personality so no more of
this info@ suchand such. comom where it
say blank dead dry LinkedIn style
writing that nobody wants to read no you
turn it from a person and that person's
personality is better than their skill
set because you are building
relationships with humans and that's
becoming more valuable that the more AI
increases and it will increase even
further in 2025 the more that increases
the more value your personality has
because people can't copy and paste your
personality somebody is going to go try
and be another Ben subtle clone a copygo
clone a throtel clone a John Carlton
clone a Gary Bena clone but that is
becoming harder and harder and harder
with the way that you write and so
understanding the things that you are
for what you know what values do you
have what are you against what values do
you hate that other people have okay and
being blatantly opinionated about those
things don't worry if people love or
hate you or anything like that because
the lukewarm copywriter will be the one
that's spit out of the mouth and not
paid attention to by anyone at all you
like my Biblical reference right there
yeah Luke war is the thing nobody wants
in 2025 because all this generic chat
chpt crap that's getting posted online
is the most boring crap in the world
which is why my newsletter again at
alland dru.com is one of the most
explosive copyrighting newsletters right
now and I want you to go get on it
Shameless plug number two I can't not
are you still not on my list you're
kidding me so personality beats skillon
now let's recap that really quick I'll
give you some tactics and I'll get you
the crap out of here okay first one is
copywriters that are athletes will be
the first ones to thrive mind I did mind
and I hit my chest on idiot mind and
body okay that's that's how it is okay
mind and body they both work well
together you take care of your body your
body will take care of your mind you'll
have mental Clarity copywriters will be
athletes the second one you are your
first client writing for yourself
putting in the Reps learning everything
that you need to do building the proof
and actually serving yourself and maybe
even maybe never hiring a client because
that is super possible in the future of
2025 and number three personality beats
skill set once you you are at a certain
level you understand the fundamentals
you are going goat mode okay you are a
great copywriter you understand
persuasion techniques you understand
closing you understand deadlines you
understand Market awareness you
understand hooks headlines leads all of
these things you understand these things
once you get them down and you're good
okay then personality is the only thing
that will take you further all right now
let's pivot I want to Pivot and give you
some TX iCal things of things that are
working tactically and that will work in
2025 and why they'll work in 2025 there
are only three types of copyrighting
that I would put my money on in 2025 and
those three have one thing in common and
I'll explain what those are in a second
but those three types of copywriting are
vsls ads and emails that's it if I were
to do anything in copyrighting in 2025
it would only be those three things vsls
ads and emails all three of those things
have one thing in common
conversion that's it okay when you're
writing for yourself or you're writing
for clients the only thing that they
truly genuinely care about is conversion
did this person's copy convert to a a
sale or a lead meaning eventually this
thing is way closer to actually putting
money in my pocket than anything else
because what is copywriting well
copywriting is salesmanship in print
right or in digital right on online
whatever it's in words salesmanship so
if your copy doesn't sell anything was
absolutely useless so a lot of people do
they've equated copyrighting with like
writing tweets writing blogs that's not
copyrighting that's content writing
writing content that leads to likes and
engagement and things like that that
stuff is dead okay AI is getting better
and better at that stuff anyway they
pumping out 50 blogs a day 50 tweets a
day that nobody's reading anyway what
you want to focus on is conversion based
copy true copywriting and the best three
ways to do that in 2025 is writing a
vssl like a sales letter right a video
sales letter because videos are
converting really really high in 2025
big shocker and so being able to write a
video sales letter as well as the
landing page itself right a video
embedded on a landing page uh that has
bullets and all that stuff classic sales
letter typing that stuff still converts
really really high the next one is like
ads writing Google ads meta ads Tik Tok
ads all those things because when you
write Those ads when you write a great
ad even if it's a script for a video ad
or the actual copy in a Facebook ad an
Instagram whatever it is those things
lead to conversion the better your copy
the more likely somebody clicks and buys
your product and the last thing my
personal favorite is emails emails are
still so freaking hot in 2025 because
they're so personal they're oneon-one
they're it's not saturated like people
think it is especially if you do it the
way El copy goat does it which I will
teach you in my upcoming course email
goat okay so make sure you go to Allen
dro.com subscribe to my email list and
you will get upcoming updates on email
goat because it is dropping in just a
couple weeks it's going to be awesome
I'm really excited about it but my
recommendation on one of those three is
I would pick
one that you are really good at because
now you can specialize which you can
charge more and get really good so me I
specialize in writing emails okay that's
my thing I don't pretend to be an expert
at writing vsls or writing ads have I
written vssl and ads yes I've written a
lot of vsls and ads am I good at it yeah
I've converted a lot okay I've made a
lot of money writing vsls and ads is it
my thing no in fact I don't even tell
tell people it's my thing I tell
everybody my only thing is email now
sure I may take some vssl some ads every
once in a while but I don't promote it I
don't talk about it I don't even make it
a big focus of mine because
specialization is one of the things that
propels you to be unique amongst the
saturated market so now I just made the
market even smaller right there's
copywriters big pond email copywriters
smaller pond so now I'm going to be the
best of email copywriters well you can
do the same be one of the best ad copyri
Google ad copywriters okay Tik Tok ad
copywriters vsl copywriters okay
whatever it is the more specialized you
can be the more you can charge and the
faster you can learn how to master it so
that would be my advice to you I gave
you the strategy and I gave you the
Tactical let's recap everything really
quick to get you going one copywriters
the best ones will be athletes two you
are your first client and maybe even
your own forever client you may not have
to ever hire a client because you have
so many customers for your own products
three personality beats skill set once
you know the fundamentals and you are
excellent at copyrighting you need to go
straight into figuring out how to use
your personality or you can do that
today as for the Tactical side you want
to be writing one of these three types
of copyrighting vsls ads or emails pair
that strategy with one of those tactics
and I guarantee you will be thriving in
an incredible industry of copyrighting
I'm excited to be in this industry I
plan on being in it for a very very long
time and I hope you do too because I'm
going to be here to invest in you in
your journey and give you the best
copyrighting knowledge here on this
channel so before you go I want to ask
you two quick things and I'm going to
give you a gift in just a second first
subscribe to this channel lets me know
that you watch the videos that you
appreciate the videos and that you
actually want more of these videos and
believe me I'm about to start making a
lot more of these videos based on
popular demand from you so thank you so
much for your support I'm really excited
we're about to hit 400 subscribers and I
can't even believe it I I really didn't
know if a hundred of you would care so
so thank you so much for your support
two I've already mentioned it a couple
times but I write emails every single
day Allen dru.com is the best place to
subscribe to my email so you can get a
first look of how I do email
copyrighting in 2024 and 2025 and lastly
I want to give you a gift when you sign
up to my email list I give you
copyrighting catalyst which is 63 cash
cow tips that you can read in 90 seconds
or less each tip and start applying them
today they are curated from me that I've
personally used and they've made me a
lot of money I packaged it together for
you for free some of the best
copyrighting advice is in there you get
it for free when you sign up on my email
list that's it that wraps us up for the
day I hope this video was incredibly
helpful for you I'm excited for the
future of copyrighting I can't wait to
see you there and I will catch you on
the next one
[Music]